[Applaudissements]
alors quand on m'a proposé de clôturer
ce tlx je me suis dit waouh quel honneur
faut savoir que je suis un adepte de
tedx depuis plus de dix ans mon le site
est rien mon ordinateur je regarde comme
ça un homme toutes les interventions
tous les talk et puis là j'étais parmi
vous et puis une fois de plus j'ai
regardé toutes ces personnes et je me
suis complètement retrouvé dans chacune
d'elles dans leur manière de voir la vie
dans leurs manières d'envisager l'avenir
dans la manière de me faire sourire de
nous faire rire de nous émouvoir de se
questionner de nous questionner et puis
on m'a dit bon ben c'est un taux de
conclure au quai nous y sommes
la fabrique de nos réalités
alors déjà quelque chose qui frappe
quand on les voit tous défiler ses
intervenants c'est qu' il n'y a rien il
est un lien entre chacun d'eux est un
lien dans lequel moi même je me retrouve
totalement et ce lien c'est la passion
la passion alors qu'ils soient
philosophe économiste chercheur danseurs
danseuses clown fouilleurs de poubelles
10 et coeur de batteries médecin
psychiatre
chacun est mû par une passion une
passion qui vont chercher dans la
vistoire profonde dans leur intimité
une passion qui les invite à se
questionner à nous questionner à agir
une passion qu'il relie aux autres et
qui le relie au monde
alors quand j'étais tout petit
vraiment très petit je faisais les
spectacles dans ma chambre
alors bon je suis pas du tout enfant de
la balle parce que mon père vient plutôt
de mule de la banque
ma mère vient plutôt du milieu de
l'université du coup rien ne me
prédestinait à devenir chanteur ou
artistes et pourtant je passais un temps
fou dans ma chambre a préparé des petits
spectacles je tendais un grand drap
blanc entre mon bureau et mon étagère et
puis je faisais des décors en papier
crépon je préparais des musiques je
préparais des histoires des petites
affiches que je collais partout dans mon
immeuble et pij invité tous les voisins
à venir voir tous mes petits spectacles
alors c'était pas des petits spectacles
parce que c'était des spectacles qui
tuerait des heures alors en plus je
supportais pas quand on parle pendant le
spectacle
alors les seuls qui étaient là et qui
obligé de revenir parce que les voisins
revenait pas c'était mes parents et mes
parents ils chuchotaient tout le temps
mais tout ça lui vient et ça lui vient
sa très envie de se mettre en scène
cette envie de chanter
bon en gros ce qui s'est passé mais
qu'est ce qu'on va faire de lui
en fait j'étais mieux mais aussi par une
passion par la passion de la scène comme
alice tout à l'heure ça d alice la clown
t elle à 17 ans voit son premier
spectacle de tous nos contemporains elle
se dit c'est ça c'est ça que je vais
faire non c'est pas ça que j'ai fait
assez ça que je dois faire et c'est ça
qui va donner du sens à tout ça si on
m'a aussi c'est ça qui a donné du sens à
tout prix alors c'est génial de
découvrir sa passion
quand on est ado quand on est enfant
parce que du coup notre vie entièrement
tendu vers un but comme ça vers un but
qui devient une évidence et ça devient
notre réalité et cette réalité on sur la
fabrique pas à pas et tous nos
intervenants on l'a vu aujourd'hui sont
mus par une passion qui les poussent à
agir à se questionner à nous questionner
puis bien sûr et à l'enfance
j'étais enfant et quand on est enfant
dans mail y aura du monde
quand on est enfant on est invincible
quand on est enfant on est capable de
tout vous savez on est comme la
grenouille dont parlait se fie au tout
début
cette grenouille qui n'écoutent rien qui
font ce qu'ils font ce qu'ils font ce
qu'ils font ce qu'ils font et qui arrive
à atteindre des sommets
et même si c'est pas des sceaux mais
c'est pas grave c'est pas les sommets on
est enfant on est quand même assez haut
et on le voit on le voit devant son
chemin est tout tracé
j'étais jeune j'étais fou que j'étais
jeune et fougueux et un jour j'entends à
la radio
tombé du ciel de jacques higelin alors
là comme alice c'est le coup de foudre
jeu devient instantanément fans j'écoute
tout j'achète tous ses albums
je connais toutes ces chansons je chante
comme lui je joue du piano comme lui je
m'habille comme lui je me coiffe comme
unis je marche comme l'i chez les mêmes
gestes que lui j'arrive même à dégoter
son numéro de téléphone personnel parce
que quand on est femme quelqu'un
forcément on veut le rencontrer
alors moi je voulais pas rencontrer pour
les autographes et c'est à moi ce que je
voulais c'était lui chanter mes chansons
que je chantais au piano comme lui alors
je l'avais son numéro de téléphone et
j'appelais j'appelais et ça
répondait chan
jamais et puis un jour chapelle et il
décroche alors là je m'en sois un toute
ma vie bien sûr lui extrêmement
désagréable mais t'es qui toi on se
connaît non on se connaît pas ou est ce
que tu as vu mon numéro
comment tu as eu mon numéro tu arrêtes
d'un péché moi tu appelles plus chez moi
ok et raccroche alors là je prends mon
courage à deux mains je prends le métro
et 45 minutes après je débarque chez lui
non parce que je l'avais aussi sur
l'adresse personnelle non mais j'étais
un vrai fan je suis un vrai fan alors je
sonne je sonne je sonne et là je le vois
il est là à la fenêtre en haut ils me
regardent
il comprend direct qui je suis
on dit c'est toi qui a appelé tout à
l'heure tu as du lotois on va y rentrer
et me voilà chez jacques higelin de la
passion à l'idée de l'idée à l'action
du rêve à la réalité j'ai 15 ans j'ai 15
ans et je chante mes chansons alors il
écoute il nous dit qu'il aime il
m'encourage et depuis ce jour là eh bien
il ya un lien un lien incroyable un lien
vous savez comme une sécurité comme
quelque chose d'extrêmement fort qui m'a
guidé toute ma vie
jusqu'à aujourd'hui comme une sécurité
émotionnelle
quand la personne la personne que vous
admirez le plus vous prend dans ses bras
et vous incite vous encourage vous
accompagne dans vos convictions vous
accompagne dans votre destinée et vous
accompagne dans vos rêves
c'est l'attachement dont par les ânes
tout à l'heure l'attachement à l'autre
parce qu'au fil de toutes ces années
jacques est devenu mon père un père
artistique
un père qui m'a guidé qui m'a accompagné
et un père que j'ai quittée dans le
cimetière du père lachaise il ya
quelques mois dans les larmes dans les
larmes et dans la joie fait un cadeau
comme des ânes tout à l'heure ça a été
adossée à un défi de la vie il faut en
prendre soin il faut en prendre soin
parce que c'est ça qui vous pousse à
regarder l'autre ensuite avec
bienveillance
essayez encore toute sa vie de regarder
l'autre avec bienveillance
puis l'enfance parce qu'avec l'enfance
on est capable de tout on a cette force
incroyable et ça on l'a vu aujourd'hui
dans tous les intervenants
c'est notre réalité intime c'est notre
conviction c'est notre conviction c'est
nos rêves
ce fils disait tout à l'heure et c'est
ce qui fait qu'on se fabrique au fur et
à mesure une réalité révèle une réalité
sublimer et tout d'un coup on arrive à
la matérialiser alors plus tard je
traîne dans une mjc et de la mjc je vois
un mec avec une crête sur la tête avec
des personnes partout tu chantes ça
c'est l'hymne de nos campagnes de nos
rivières de nos montagnes de la vie mal
du monde animal il devient fort juste
hectares de vocal de nos campagnes
bon alors là c'est un second choc en
fait je viens de voir dix mots je viens
de rencontrer visimmo manu toute sa
bande
et alors là on devient ami on commence à
faire de la musique c'était il ya 25 ans
et tous nos potes autour de nous dire
mais c'est génial quand vous chantez ça
sonne terriblement fait un groupe il
crée le groupe essaie des premiers
heurts du groupe tryo alors trio on est
les enfants de brassens
on est les enfants de renault on est les
enfants de thiéfaine et on est les
enfants dit cela alors pour ceux qui
connaissent pas une colonne vertébrale
d'un trio quelque chose d'assez fort
c'est peut-être le côté politique et le
côté écolo
alors bien sûr les chansons écologique
et parler d'écologie surtout en musique
je vous rappelle qu'il ya 25 ans c'était
complètement has been savons visée on
disait oui oui oui alors les glaciers
les glaciers vont fondre on dirait des
espèces qui vont partir
on disait oui r c'était en fait une
réalité mais c'était une réalité
extrêmement lointaine alors en plus nous
en musique ont été habillés avec des
pantacourts alors tout le monde nous
prenait pour des fumeurs de joints tu
vas ont pensé qu'on habitait dans des
tipis au bord de feu qu'on jouait de la
guitare toute la journée en bouffant des
graines tu vas juin
et nous on s'en fout on fonce on chante
nos chansons on y croit c'est engager le
public est là et là on commence à faire
des tournées et des tournées et ça dure
et quel plaisir et c'est encore la
passion
et puis au bout d'un moment est assez
rapidement on décide de passer aux actes
alors les actes quand on parlait contre
on passe pour un écolo bas c'est par
exemple faire le bilan carbone de la
tournée parce que bon les mangeurs de
graines à un quantité en toute la
journée dans leurs énormes autour bus et
qui parcourt toute la france tous les
jours tous les jours eva l'énergie on en
dépense on en dépense et là je fais le
lien avec alex alex qui vient juste de
passer savent et le disent et coeur de
batterie le fouilleurs de poubelles
parce que nous les batteries sais pas si
vous savez mais sur une tournée alors là
les piles
il y en a 5 à des piles partout dans la
dans les micros dans la dentelle chef il
y en a dans les packs il y en a dans les
guitares et puis c'est assez pour chaque
musicien plus des techniciens
tu vas vous savez les piles en plus je
la cite savez on les suspects jusqu'au
bout parce qu'on va quand même pas
prendre le risque que le micro du
chanteur s'arrête en plein milieu du
show pour aller jusqu'au bout de la pile
alors du coup on se retrouve des
milliers et des milliers et des milliers
et des milliers pile est alors elles
sont là comme ça alors bon nous notre
solution a été quand même plus facile à
trouver que celle d'alex nous c'était
chargeur de piles ou alors c'était des
dizaines et des dizaines et des dizaines
de chargeurs de piles sur le côté de la
scène qui tout âge en effet ça alors
aujourd'hui ça paraît basique il ya 20
ans on était quand même un petit peu
moins alors avec ça
alex c'est quelque chose qui nous paraît
nous complètement naturelle complètement
habituel je peux alors lui il va essayer
de du séqué de ticket to sable comprend
le fonctionnement et il va essayer de
trouver une solution pour ne plus jeter
ce qui contient encore de l'énergie
comme nous aujourd'hui on va essayer de
garder ne pas jeter toute cette énergie
qu'on a eu pendant sont uniques
essayez de penser autrement
pareil à l'époque sais pas si vous vous
souvenez ont ils tourné dans les zéniths
et à la fin des concerts j'ai passé
brusquement les fausses
les jeunes sa phase et dans les fossés
tech
de gobelets en plastique et y en avait
partout alors là c'est pareil très vite
on disait ben on va faire autrement
on avait nos gobelets recyclé avec
marqueterie au dessus on a embauché une
personne
on a pris un camion on a acheté des
tables date est celle où on mettait les
la vaisselle dans les camions et à
chaque fois tous les jours dans les
zénith on les ressort t et on lavait les
gobelets et ont légué l'avait alors du
coup on a prouvé que c'était viable
économiquement
du coup on a vu une personne en plus sur
la route les gens soient il partait avec
leur gobelet soit il nous le donner ça
fait de l'argent ça paye l'emploi et
donc voilà et c'était possible alors
aujourd'hui je vous dis ça ça vous
paraît complètement basique parce que
tous les festivals le fond et même les
zénith se met à le faire mais ya vingt
ans c'était beaucoup moins évident
penser autrement
croire en ce qu'on fait et faire ce que
l'on croit et être responsable de ce
qu'on laisse derrière nous
lauriane tout à l'heure nous a rendu
responsable d'un paysage de montagne
avec une question sur notre faculté à
agir face à la crise écologique et en
filigrane une autre question bien plus
importante encore qui est est ce que la
crise écologique nous laisse le choix
agir lorient nous l'expliqué tout à
l'heure à gien en fonction de nos
valeurs des valeurs fondamentales qui
sont extrêmement ancré en nous ce sont
des valeurs inviolable et ce sont ces
valeurs qui vont nous guider dans notre
action
pour pierre là on est au pied de la
montagne pierre puisqu'il avait le trac
on est au pied de la montagne et il sera
bientôt trop tard pour agir et pour
sauver l'humanité
du coup ça nous impose de produire plus
avec moins
ça nous impose d'unir nos forces d'unir
d'unir nos actions alors voilà
l'histoire de pierre à la finale parce
que pierre il a quitté sa vie citadine
il a quitté ses sociétés et je me suis
inséré qu'il revient de loin vous leur
parlerez tout à l'heure et il a retrouvé
son visage son village natal il y
revenue à la nature il est revenu aux
sources
et voilà il a pris ce qui existait déjà
et il en a développé un concept un
concept durable
un concept profondément moderne l'aqua
pony alors on peut regarder comme un
illuminé
il reste artisans ça reste un artisan
artisan d'une nouvelle réalité on peut
le regarder comme un illuminé je pense
qu'il ya la source d'une nouvelle
manière de produire et d'une nouvelle
manière aujourd'hui de consommer et puis
bon la pierre c'est bien de passer pour
un illuminé aussi un ce que finalement
on peut passer pour un illuminé quand
nous on a la conviction profonde d'être
dans notre propre réalité
finalement aujourd'hui tous les
intervenants étaient complètement il lui
et je vais vous dire quelque chose c'est
à moi de vous le dire parmi tous ces
intervenants
aujourd'hui il y avait un imposteur
il y avait un comédien il y avait une
personne qui vous a fait croire qu'elle
est et ce qu'elle n'était pas et qui
vous a complètement mener en bateau
[Applaudissements]
en même temps vous savez quoi on est sur
une scène sur une scène on est là pour
jouer un rôle
alors bien sûr sur une scène tout est
possible et puis vous aussi en tant que
public vous avez un rôle
vous aussi vous avez un rôle ne pas tout
prendre pour argent comptant d'exercer
votre bon sens benoît nous l'a expliqué
tout à l'heure avec l'essor de l'acte et
de technologie l'intelligence
artificielle est de dire que l'essor de
cette technologie allait nous imposer à
tous d'exercer notre capacité notre nos
capacités critiques individuelles notre
sens commun bon alors c'est une
imposteure tajan bas qu'ils aimeraient
que le balancer tous à être les dykes
c'est de l'arnaqué madoff
vous savez si on sait pas ce qui est fou
on peut pas savoir ce qui est vrai je
vous rassure je vous rassure
aujourd'hui tout était vrai n'en doutez
pas regarder le monde tel qu'il est et
non pas tel qu'on se l'imaginent
regardez les hommes regardez les fils
regardez les campagnes regardez les
océans avec hugo hugo verlomme tard le
nom vers l'homme ça s'invente pas vers
l'homme
hugo nous parle d'un proverbe hawaïens
et ce proverbe moody ne tourne pas le
dos à la mer et nous dit aussi jamais la
mère n'a eu autant besoin de nous et
jamais nous nous avons les votes ont
besoin de la mer il nous parle de ses
magnifiques initiatives toutes ces
initiatives et on le comprend on
comprend que chaque goutte d'eau compte
c'est le principe des petites victoires
il ya quelques semaines j'étais au maroc
avec le mouvement colibris le mouvement
colibris c'est un mouvement qui a été
initiée par pierre rabhi scierie dion et
bien d'autres et ce mouvement a été
inspiré par une légende une légende
amérindienne que je vais vous conter si
vous ne la connaissez pas cette légende
raconte un jour il lut un grand incendie
tous les oiseaux étaient tous les
animaux étaient apeurés
tous les animaux était terrassé tous
sauf un le petit colibri et le petit
colibri va chercher quelques gouttes
avec son bec qui ramène comme ça sur le
feu alors au bout d'un moment le tattoo
pour qui cette agitation semble bien
dérisoire s'adresse au colibri et lui
colibri tu sais que tu vas pas pouvoir
éteindre le feu avec ses petites gouttes
et le colibri lui répond je le sais mais
je fais ma part
alors aujourd'hui nous sommes tous des
petits colibri des petit colibri face au
défi titanesque qui nous attend notre
éthique doit rester intact l'impossible
l'imprévisible peut devenir réalité pour
vous dire aussi qu'il faut vivre et
qu'il faut croire en ses passions qu'il
faut croire en ses rêves qu'il y a des
codes
oui mais que ces codes sont faits pour
être bousculées
malmenés je finirai par une intervention
qui m'a profondément touché je pense
vous aussi celle de céline et céline
c'est un véritable pied de nez à la vie
de la voir s'épanouir danser devant nous
danser pour nous
avec une envie comme ça la prendre très
très fort dans ses bras
la serre est comme ça très très très
très très très fort entendre ses enfants
nous rappelle que si nous sommes là
aujourd'hui c'est pour construire leur
réalité
nous sommes là pour eux la route est
très très très longue mais le futur est
extrêmement réjouissant
[Applaudissements]